[Music]
so now the segue into the switch itself
yeah Jimmy his review is up it's live
what uh what do you give it we don't
give scores yes he gave it a there's no
joke with a switch there there's no easy
one but P you've probably spent the most
time in the office with it what's what's
uh what's your overall in a sentence
we're gonna talk more than his sentence
but right now hit me with the synopsis
the things that Nintendo promised aren't
just marketing speak I definitely felt
myself experiencing these you know like
great moments for having a console that
is both a portable and something you can
play in your TV and I think it's got
great build quality and in terms of
technical performance like yeah it
doesn't stand up to your playstation 4
xbox one but here so far I don't care
yeah it for what it is I think it's
really good I also think the amount of
technology they packed into the joy
comes is really impressive like the way
I went to a GDC switch thing and the
rumble like the you can get so many
distinct sensations from it HD rumble
yeah it's like it's it's hard to
describe obviously because it's
definitely feeling based but I was
really impressed with it just as far as
like I don't intend like Nintendo just
isn't focused on competing with the
technical prowess of like ps4 xbox one
which doesn't matter to me but I I was
really impressed with how they hold up
and like how good they feel to hold I
was really surprised because they're so
small i thought i was gonna feel awkward
with it and I didn't hmm so I really
liked that too i like the different
controller options and there's a reason
to use all of them yeah yeah I wouldn't
say it's overwhelming per se but I
definitely you know you first sit down
just like any council you first sit down
and figure it out but with this it's
like okay I can play like a handheld
with the joy comes in either side of the
tablet I can dock that and put these in
this like wireframe essentially to play
them that will also charge them oh well
you have to buy the one that will charge
them right we just had that I could play
the pro controller I can play if I want
to play a multiplayer game which have
you done much with like the holding the
joy cons like by its selling a little
bit of snipper clips at the New York
event a couple
to go okay um but no I mean you know
you've got games like street fighter
bomber man yes you know when to switch
isn't really like that but no the
trailer showed people playing like the
next Mario Kart like that right yeah
it's so in that sense it's not ideal but
that said it is it's a very sleek
solution for multiplayer that I think
people will you know adapt to when the
situation dictates that hey let's play
some games together I don't want to have
two big controllers with me this is what
we've got let's do it yeah and I also
really like playing in handheld I i
really love handheld gaming probably
because i'm super nearsighted um and
playing on TV sometimes I if text is
small I get really irritated but I also
it's I thought maybe it would be a
little cumbersome I love my 3ds and I
love the size of it I have an XL and I
thought maybe like oh I'm gonna this is
going to be too big for me to really
play handheld for an extended period of
time and I haven't had that experience
I've really enjoyed it it's super
comfortable and I like having that
option it's something I thought would
maybe feel gimmicky or like oh I'm not
actually going to use this this way but
I really am and I like playing handheld
actually probably more than any other
way I was taken aback by how good it
looks on that when you're playing
handheld I mean obviously it's not it's
not like 3ds graphics we know it's
better but I still like pulling it out
there's Jeff there's our tech editor
Jimmy right now trying out but i looked
at i was playing breath of the wild last
night I had this moment where I docked
it and then I like [ __ ] I gotta go my
pockets that big what I wouldn't i
don't--that's I'm not gonna put in my
pocket but maybe he just I don't have
nice khakis like Jimmy does uh yeah this
thing Pete what are your thoughts in the
portability aspects I think you said you
played a fair amount of breath of wild
and handheld right yeah super
comfortable to hold its my preferred way
to play zelda okay at the moment but
I've spent a lot of time with the game
so like I fed this very personal
connection to it and just sort of like
tuck into a couch and like be there with
it you know and right in front my face
that's pretty good yeah it's still just
as good on a TV no but yeah in terms of
portability so far so good the battery
life is basically about three hours
which i think is fair given what the
system is it's hard to compare it to
some
like an iphone or a 3d I mean this is
running games that I've never seen run
this you know zeldo just looks
incredible on this playing in handheld
mode and I've never seen a game look
that good on a portable device before so
I mean we talked about this several
episodes ago about you know games that
are made specifically for a handheld
that you're playing like 10-15 minutes
to time on your commute sorry sources
which someone someone in the twitch chat
forgive me if I didn't see your new
times like zero access your said is that
a Nintendo switch in your pocket or you
just happy to see me sorry uh Kelly
never mind I talked to her for that I'm
sorry like it was funny after seeing
Jimmy put the new times which is I ok
anyway I don't remember what I was
saying damn it yeah I'm so sorry i just
saw that it was good yeah what was I
talking about games that are designed
for handheld that you play like on a
commute and you can kind of stop and
start vs. games that are switch games
are maybe more geared towards you're not
playing on the go you have the option to
take it with you and then set it up
wherever your destination is I think
it's a difference by a carrying case i
can tell you having using one it for
sure great let's put it ran my backpack
I don't worry about it but yeah I stared
for every switch in the office that
doesn't have a screen protector or a
case I she's gonna get banged around
yeah I remember I was really nervous
putting in my backpack I was like uh I
put like a sweater around it I make sure
I'm doing all these like low-tech hacks
because they don't have a carrying case
right now yeah I put like a breath the
wild t-shirt around and I found in my
desk was appropriate that works what was
like the cali from your experience when
you were playing you said you prefer
handheld where did you take out or were
you mainly just going to different rooms
and like your apartment or something oh
i was just kind of hanging out in the
house um i have been i've been hesitant
to take it out like on the train me just
because of embargo stuff honestly i
don't want people to like bug me i don't
want people to talk to me when i'm on
the train for like anytime I never want
people to talk to me yeah on the train
um or any time but ever
uh so I but I did I was so tempted uh
cuz i took a longer train than i
normally do the other day and I was like
I really want to take this out and play
and then i restrained myself but um for
the most part is taking it from the
office to my house to a different room
in the house is like I just love that I
you know I don't have to stop playing
because I'm cooking something yeah and
my room is downstairs in the kitchens
upstairs you know we kind of touched on
this already but using breath awhile
there's like a frame of reference how do
things look on the sweatshirt oh great I
mean there's very little if any anti
aliasing so you see some jaggies but
that game's art style kind of drives
well you know it's more than that though
it's the game supports Lex when it does
chug it's because it's it's dealing with
a lot of like like physical logic in
terms of like okay well how do you move
through grass and how does wind affect
grass like those sort of things so it
actually looks technically impressive in
some ways but clearly it's a there's
striking a balance between you know
visual fidelity and frame rate and all
that but I think I think it looks great
yeah I really like the way Zelda looks
on it yeah like I said I was pretty I
like how it looks a lot and handheld and
it fell pretty good in handheld the one
thing I know sudden I don't know if this
was just like the switch i was using the
joy cons felt slightly loose when i was
holding in handheld like kind of they
didn't it didn't feel like one thing it
felt like i could tell they were
separate from the tablet a little bit it
wasn't like they were falling off but
they were a tiny bit like hmm you're the
one that we are sharing that has is like
that but for the most part they aren't
like that okay yeah mine doesn't feel
yeah I think maybe we didn't we just put
them in weird the reason you broke it is
my fault yeah there's a time when I
found myself like wondering if that was
the case I was kind of just like
twerking them a little bit yeah and it
was like plays at working you said
torquing more torque values that's
working Victoria Pierce dingo show you
it was like okay if I really really try
I can feel this give but like in normal
circumstances I feel like this thing is
really sturdy that's it don't drop it I
don't trust that the sort of the latches
are really that sturdy mhm so you're
gonna have to baby this thing it's not
going to be like a phone you can toss
around in your 3ds I don't think it'll
be this like really durable
piece of equipment it's still it's it's
still not a console right but it's it's
something you need to be mindful not
everyone's as strong as you though I
mean yeah I'm a real strong dude you
should also just take care of your
belongings Thanks sure a big blank spot
and her knowledge of the switch is like
internet capabilities who knows Calvin
Delaney on Twitter kinda just answer the
question but he said does the switch
have a way to sign into the internet on
trains or in hospitals does it have a
browser ah there's no browser that I've
seen but what I do know that I can
confirm which i think is pretty rad is
that it will support like connections to
networks where you have to like go to a
web page to login and so yes like maybe
the hospital near the hotel here on our
Wi-Fi network because we can't for
whatever reason get on certain networks
wirelessly that'll work yes what do you
think of the like the home menu the
browser in general saris like the
console browser slick right now but it's
all pretty basic like they're adding a
few things coming lunch day but I love
the little sound effects a lot of little
animations it doesn't feel overburdened
like any other mobile device I'm used to
using it's cleaner than the 3ds it's
cleaner than the Vita yeah it's just a
really slick interface that just has
what you need Kelly you're saying you
prefer to play at hand held again but
how did you feel like actually switching
between the TV and the handheld like how
fast was it how responsive out simple to
use is it it didn't it wasn't that
difficult of the only thing I had
trouble with his I didn't read the
instructions very well and so it was
like oh press Eleanor and then a and I
was just pressing L&R cuz i just didn't
touch the handheld yeah to get the
because i put the joy cons in the kind
of the boxy looking controller
configuration which looks a lot more
uncomfortable than it is like i said
it's all a cooler small but it it feels
a little small but the controller
configurations for the most part all
work for me pretty well depending on
what I'm playing but yeah that was just
a error a user hair where it just didn't
read the instructions cuz I was so
excited to play but by and large you
know you but it's pretty I in like two
seconds later it's on your TV yes not a
point out and you're ready to go super
convenient and well I guess that's not
really the word I was looking for it's
it's it doesn't feel cumbersome it
doesn't feel like a chore like
gotta get up and do this and then wait
for it to change just yeah it just
happens last question on Twitter from
kirsten hudson kind of a future question
do you think nintendo will follow sony
and microsoft's lead and releasing like
a switch pro or something similar
absolutely yeah you they have to remand
they already do that with 3ds also i
mean like they they have a press there's
a precedent for that yeah but i think
it's even more likely now because
they're working with nvidia to make
their chips and videos a company that
goes through iterations of their
hardware and it's not like Nintendo has
to have someone make really like custom
stuff for them right and i think the
form factor will allow you to replace
something just like the tablet or just
the controller so that having to do the
whole package yeah i would not be
surprised in fact i expect them to do it
yeah
[Music]